what's with the jeans what's up with it
we bring into your crazy looks crazy
lugs we got we're gonna get us some
crazy looks here in a second well I was
doing how does he do it babe you did
Romy's what's up homies god is good
you feel me for real oh shout to
everybody all over the world doing a
thing stuff like that and stuff like
that is the best yeah that's good right
now your vlog I don't know if you've
seen everybody listening seen Tommy's
vlog oh yeah but it's up on your mom's
house pike yeah shit I can pull it I
mean this is all part of sure and you
threw down the gauntlet well shit I
didn't know you were rushing the end of
this stuff so I just got excited for
sure but I just got me I'm so fired up
about you're challenging him I I wanted
to go there well yeah okay well for
people that don't know you know my man
Loucks
you know I sort of I sort of took his
original this video as I thought he was
talking to me kind of yeah yeah yeah
it's crazy looks right here homey no say
you frills dope so it's all about the
movement like you have is he's got he's
got that swag for sure yeah so for reals
though he talks about he talks some shit
you know he gets in everybody doing
atheist stuff like that
fire is just a free shadowboxing fire
sessions I wouldn't mess with crazy
loads I feel like he's not afraid to do
it in Walmart and show everybody that's
what I'm saying so then this other dude
me decided you know to talk back to
Chris you're for real though guys good
you know I'm saying
shout out to everybody all over the
world doing a thing this stuff like that
yeah you know I'm saying did you just
get training no days off you know I mean
now like my boy Burke
getting all fat and shit on cholesterol
medication fuck that shit
yeah you like crazy lobes see putting it
down now it's totally you know I mean I
respect the shit crazy looks yeah for
being you know legit being like yeah
he's in the game he's in the game yeah
and you know he's in the shout-out game
he's in the rap he's a rapper also I
didn't know oh I didn't know that yeah
but he raps a lot and then he you know I
just I basically put this out there so
that he could see it and then maybe if
he wanted to do that fight for charity
because I you know I am you know
everyday look man just wanted to give
you a challenge video you know why don't
you and I
you know step in the brain shit you
could show me some of your moves we
could sell tickets we could donate on to
charity we could do winner-takes-all
I noticed that he he does know how to
throw a jab he knows that I throw a hook
right he throws an uppercut but then he
does really unusual sky punches or like
he go so I figured if I am gonna step in
the ring with them I have to kind of get
my skype punch game down so I at the end
of this video I just do a train for
weighted sky punches so what they're
called Skype punches yeah tell those but
not but I'm not doing I don't consider
myself doing kettlebells I think I'm
just doing weighted sky play I see
you're saying yeah because it's kind of
the same right movement yep you know
yeah I know in time I don't feel me I'm
saying I mean if you want to get a
better idea of what I'm talking about
you can look at these right here these
are what I would say are like his
probably what he's best known for oh
right
you can see sea sky punch punch punch
got it
BAM sky punch it's got a ham it's got
sky punch mm-hmm oh great maybe that's
why they call him crazy low yeah that's
his signature move yeah damn got a lot
of speed dude I don't know how you're
gonna fight this guy he's got all the
moves yeah I know it's pretty real it is
pretty real and I got a I got a make
sure that I'm ready for it you know
you're not afraid I wouldn't say that
but I'm ready to you know see where this
takes me
yeah I was brought it was brought to my
attention that there are some other
crazy love things we could we should
check out okay
one of course is his rap rapping prowess
okay this is a this is a crazy locus one
here well you really are in love with
crazy locus right now it's really normal
what what's the fascination with him so
much why do y down the crazy locus
rabbit hole well no man I mean he just
is interesting to me you know what about
his style appeals to you the most
probably just that he doesn't give a
fuck I kind of really I was like that
about people yeah there you go
fuck man he's really himself and I like
you know I like fighters should like
that rain what are you sure you want to
be fighting this guy I don't know it
that's why I'm starting to train harder
yeah I'm not sure you wanna oh wait look
at the header on that which one crazy
let's scroll up I want to see up higher
up look at that crazy face he's crazy
loads I don't know baby I kind of don't
want you fighting this guy now because
it I don't know if he's stable enough
you know you don't think he's stable
scary well this is like a lot of the
fighting stuff but for a long time it
was about rapping you know he was really
interesting
helos right here Jimmy Jimmy - you know
I'm saying straight up though chuckles
out present lows got to keep pushing
with this ambition with this dream Chris
and Lowe's ain't fitting yes you know
what I mean yes indeed Chris hello spray
pranks that he crazy Lopes is gonna pass
the mic so this home you can do it right
yeah man you know yeah
there's different levels there's so much
happening with crazy loads you know it's
like it you know there's like people are
like I'm a writer director producer like
he's that guy he's that guy that can
wear so many hats yeah he didn't know
you
he's so talented yeah you can't contain
that kind of talent homie yeah this is a
freestyle it looks like right here
Doug's pushing these game crazy loads
don't give a fuck
Chrissy Lopes is gonna spit don't fear
what I said I straight do a phoner kid I
straight to affirmative brain humans
gaming every bueno playing what I guess
just say cuz the lows all about getting
paid all about his dub for show
something y'all used to know without rap
to be a yeah it's not that good so he
only moves his mouth - everything else
is perfectly stove you notice that like
you know blinking just kind of well I
gotta say I was getting really into
preparing for the fight uh-huh and you
know I was watching a lot of his boxing
videos reading yeah studying tape seeing
like what is my opponent you know
because in that video that I put out
obviously I'm challenging him yeah turns
out crazy looks might not even be well
yeah what do you mean well wait a minute
not well how like he has a cold or
something worse brain not well
yeah what a shocker you're kidding well
I mean here's a mess of weird here's an
email we got from a listener who also
teaches people with special needs he
says hi Hitler mommies I work with
special needs kids I'm on spring break
so I had some extra time on my hands and
I think I can fill in the blanks a bit
on crazy loaves that watch those YouTube
videos such as this wonderful rap
classic cop car oh that's the one we
just saw right he was rapping next to a
car park
later
okay we get the idea
anyways so he says judging from his
somewhat slurred repetitive speech and
wide-set eyes I wanted to at first say
fetal alcohol syndrome but I think that
crazy Lok's yeah more than likely is on
the autism spectrum
and probably to the more severe end of
it at that yeah his occasional speech
disfluency and intense non blinking eye
patterns make me think this seriously he
doesn't blink surefire sign right there
he also has some delusions of grandeur
and a general detachment from reality
which are also signs he's a bit touched
as you'd say also watching him spar and
his movements in his rap video led me to
believe he has some form of dyspraxia
dyspraxia how do you say that I'm not a
medical professional time another
symptom of the spectrum which can
manifest itself with difficulties
understanding movement patterns punches
directly out ports in this case or
things like handwriting in school issues
with motor skills shuffling feet while
spire aspiring poor balance mistime
movements general flailing about this is
just one man's opinion which it's legit
to say yeah any way you slice it this
dude is pretty fucked up I love the show
keep those jeans way up high and tight
by Hitler PS I'd rather be retarded ah
it's not so bad we're trying to be what
can be happy and have good lives you
know I take that over grandpa's dick in
my mouth every day even with the funnel
cake yeah but your Grandpa's not he's
not
it's exciting your mouth in that
scenario he's just jacking you off
alright yeah that's true that is a
little less severe than psych way less
severe yeah lowing your grandfather so
we're just getting like a nice handjob
from a nice buzzes hands are kind
old and softer to do it unless he did a
lot of manual labor and then his hands
we really yard and it could be calloused
Yannick rusty hands but still is what
was your grand grand dad's hands like
they were nice
so he we got a nice soft see mmhmm yeah
you never I finally picked up ever no
fun
I don't know never brought it up never
brought it up so this is kind of
depressing yeah it's another funny funny
background story to a clip that you
presented thank you well I'm saying I'm
glad I know this is a depression for me
now is that I don't think I can fight
him no but you maybe you could rap
battle him that really good idea right
yeah yeah you know I'm saying yeah all
people out there doing it well no not if
he's severely mentally affected it
doesn't it doesn't mean that it can't be
a good rapper do you think so no it's
just just affect his stuff remember that
kid that he did the rap battle and he
was like you like Rosie O'Donnell had a
bisexual baby shower that he actually
was really good at rapping right it
doesn't mean they clown them and
everything yeah but he was really good
so we don't know crazy looks could
surprise you
true he could you know what's happen to
some creative at place that you don't
know about because of his autism what do
you want to bet on that like a back rub
a back rub you think it'll be good
mm-hmm crazy looks you don't know